hello everyone and welcome to our
webinar
entitled single cell multi-omics dna
methylation
and 3d genome i am kenneth day
a senior scientist here in epigenetics
group at zymo research
and i will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational webinar
is presented by lab roots and brought to
you by zymo research
dymo research is known as the
epigenetics company
and has specialized in products that
facilitate epigenetics research for its
customers for over 15 years
as our name implies we offer a full
end-to-end epigenetics approach
for ngs based profiling of chromatin dna
methylation and gene expression
our workflow begins with nucleic acid
extraction
through bioinformatics support for our
customers
zymo remains as the gold standard for
bisulfite conversion
especially for single cell methylome
analysis
the exploding number of published single
cell methylone studies
show continued use of xymobisulfite
conversion
whether by using traditional sort
methods or on single cell platforms
to learn more please visit the link on
your screen
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the
end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen i
now present today's speaker
dr yaping liu is an assistant professor
from cincinnati children's hospital
medical center
in human genetics he earned his phd from
the epigenome center
at the university of southern california
where he developed the innovative gnome
seek methodology
he completed the postdoctoral training
in the kellis lab
at the broad where he contributed to the
roadmap epigenomics and gtex consortia
that pioneered definitions of epigenetic
states
across human cells and tissues in tune
with his record
his recent work unifies profiling 3d
chromatin
architecture by high c together with
bisulfite conversion to analyze
methylation
in the context of pads within single
cells
to resolve structure at this level
within single cells is a major advance
for epigenetics research
without further ado i would like to
point attendees to a more complete
biography
of our speaker located in the biography
tab at the top of your screen
dr liu you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone uh my name is yat ping
liu
it's my pleasure to present my recent
work single cell martial mix
dm methylation and 3d genome
[Music]
so the research goal of my lab is try to
bridge the gap between genetic variation
and phenotypic
variations so the focus of my lab is
actually on the epigenetic side
the reason we choose epigenetics is for
examination
it's a stable heritable phenotype
resulting from changes in chromosome
without alteration in dna sequence
so basically as the two sides one side
is the phenotype
the other side is also a has the
epigenetic multiplication on dna
sequence itself
so it actually integrates signals from
genomes
of course the confounding issue and as
well as the environment and disease
so analyze the signal from epigenetics
will tell us
how the genome and the disease-like
symptom of phenotype variations
how they interact with each other
so in terms of epigenetics there is many
layers in different resolutions
so for uh like one base parallel
resolution
the cytosine would get modified by dnmt
or d modified by the tab domain attack
sorry test
test family that will demath latest and
after like about 100 base pair or kb
resolution
the dna sequence will wrap around the
nucleosomes
and in more than like kb to 25 kb
resolution
you will see the loop like in different
regions of the genome will loop
around each other and function regular
elements will interact with each other
and in like 100kb to mass basis
resolution
you will see the topological social
domain so the street the genome the
linear genome will optimize
in the three-digit way that were folded
into the nuclear memory
and in resolution larger will see the
territory and compartment
changes so there's many layers and this
in different resolution across the
epigenomes
and gene methylation and 3d genome both
played a very critical role for gene
regulations
like this has been known for decades the
dna methylation
in cancers they will silence the gene
from
the methylation promoter with silence to
gene expression and the
methylation will activate the genes and
also for the
imprinting regions as well as the
inactivation
they are all associated with and during
the development there is a
different there's two waves about the
methylation
so all these tails like the skin
methylation plays a very important role
for gene regulations
and and very recently the dna methylate
the 3d genome
also more and more studies focus on the
three region and tells that
the quantum loops also cares a lot a lot
about the gene regulation
information such as the enhancer there
were loop
and accurate gene which is about maybe
100 kb
away in the downstream or upstream
why in this interaction maybe get
disrupted in cancers
very recently like some groups find out
the gene methylation which is perfect
people think it's correlated in local
scale like
uh call it in just like cbg island
or like 300 base power away from each
other's
people find out actually the
implications are also correlated with
each other in different resolutions
like john hopkins group find out the
genetic controlled
methylation clusters and also queen john
glad
in ucfp find out these methylation
hepatite blocks
and even like for very recently in
uh by casper hansen's group and john
hopkins they find out
the long-range correlation uh
by discovered by proficient methylation
of ray data
they find that the sum of this
correlation can happen even like
100kb away and if you look at the
app you calculate the correlation of the
imagination
and then get the first principal
component you find out
there uh actually the eigenvector looks
similar as
high c it's compartment a and b data
while if you
are using the mean modulation level you
don't see that
results so which indicates that the
imagination may have some
of the long-range correlation but
currently there's no existing
at that time when we publish the paper
there's no existing method that can
directly measure long-range
interactional action
signals right now of course there's some
like nano
pore sequencing that you might able to
get some information from that
so for those of you who are not familiar
with high c
i'll just briefly introduce what is the
high c technology
uh basically high c can physically link
the dna from the same allele
over large genomic distance there is a
few steps of the high c
first you after you get the nuclei uh we
will
crosslink cross-linked across to the
cross link
so the dna which is far away from each
other
the proteins there were cross-linked and
then after that you use the restroom
enzyme to digest the dna
and at that you feel thing and feel the
biotin
and ligated them so the region that is
far away from each other will be
like it together and then as you purify
and digest get rid of this reverse cross
link
and then purify and pull down by
biotin to enrich the these long-range
interactions
you can use the pell and sequencing to
get the
uh to get a measure of how frequently
two regions in the genome that interact
with each other
so in like 2013 people find out since
you are able to use this
sequence information to measure how
frequent these two genomes two region of
genome entitled each other
the genetic variation in these sequences
will also be
evaluated so taking advantage of that
people are able to face
their genetics and get the phase genome
by
high c sequence and in our
our hypothesis is since the genetic
variation can be
linked by this high c experiment
how about the genetic genetic multi
epigenetic modification such as the
in methylation in cytosine
so this is a uh collaboration uh works
with dr binjam's group
and what dr bochang lee in various group
uh so we develop take advantage of that
we developed this
method high c technology which is
combining the high throughput
high c the chromosome confirmation
capture and
the bisulfite sequencing together so
we're able to
measure two modalities at the same time
in a single experiment
so the basic idea is simple that the
first few steps are similar as
in studio high c but just after we get
by team uh pulled down and enriched
the large interactions we'll do the
additional steps
caused by sulphide conversion and then
after by sulfide conversion we do the
pell-end sequence in addition to get the
3d general information we're also
able to get the endogenous dna
methylation information
at the same time so there's some
difficult challenges for analyze this
data
think about like the high c uh
interaction high c data actually create
a lot of
chi mercury and by sulfide stabilization
actually sometimes also will create a
lot of chemical risk
so this is similar as people when doing
their
rna-seq if you try to map the wrist
across two different axon boundary
and try to figure out where they are
coming from in the genome
in honesty we are able to get the help
from this
axon annotation but in pi c actually two
regions of genome they may be
math bases away from each other so it's
very hard to have these regions
if there there's a lot of kinetic risk
so if we are using like uh so using
traditional geometrical mapping tools
like bismarck or pwa mass
we actually get a very low massability
uh mass degrees
and considering that only a small
proportion of this incident high c
maturities
is about only 30 to 40 percent of these
rates are actually
from long range impacted with to
evaluate 3d genome
if using the traditional way to map the
maxwell high series will get very few
risk that can
measure the 3d genomes so we actually
developed a
computational pipeline uh take the long
page of the bwa
we did some modification on that and
then allow us to map
the wrist the connectivity more
efficiently
therefore we're able to get much better
mapping comparing to the traditional
institute without bisulfi treatment
so we also did some like simulations
like
the mapping accuracy comparing uh
comparing with the traditional beast
mark is similar
uh and the dm methylation calling are
very similar as traditional
uh using the traditional way for maximum
weight
okay so after we conquer the analysis uh
challenges the first thing we do is try
to
check one another our assay can
recapture the high quality 3d genomes
so for those of you who are familiar
with the high c analysis
this is a typical log log 10 plot in
high c analysis
so basically we comparing the metal high
c and c to high c
from the same mouse esl line and then we
measure
that the distance of the fraction of the
weight
at a specific distance and then we plot
the distributions
the methyl hyphen looks like similar as
in situ high c
and we also match the libel complexity
even after bisulfite conversion the
methyl high c library complexity looks
similar as in pseudohypers
in different biological wrap case and we
also measure the 3d genome
in different resolution from the
topological social domains resolution
like
250kb resolution to like 25kb or 5kb
resolution that you are able to call the
loops
they are largely similar and as well as
colder
so also we check quantified uh quantify
the overlap of population social domain
uh called by nc high c and method high c
as well as the quantum groups called by
jewish pipeline
uh they're largely overlapped with each
other into between two technologies in
the same cell lines
so second is we try to quantify where
when i
can recapture the high quality dna
methylation levels
so the first thing we did was we checked
uh
the cpg size we captured by these two
assays
so the ghost stands the horizontal
bisulfide sequence and from the same
cell
line they capture slightly more cpg than
the metal high c
and we also check the dna methylation
concordance
at each single cpg size they're largely
similar between the two assays
uh so each dot here represents a single
cpg and then
we measure the dna isolation fraction
between horizontal bisulfite sequencing
and
method high c the overall correlation
goes up to 0.7
and we look at what is the overall
geometrician level between the two assay
in the genome browser view that
methylation
in methyl height c looks similar as
horizon by sulfide sequencing and get
decreases
at this open containing region such as
dj island or cdcf
occupied regions so in conclusion
our essay are able to capture the 3d
genome and imagination are the same dna
molecules
so since we're able to get the dna
methylation from each read
so we're able to actually uh by the
length degrees
in to link the rays at the contain
groups the angle 1 and mp2 were able to
get the methylation on each suite
so this is not so take advantage of that
this is the better example like the
imprinting gene regions
the loop anchor regions were able to get
the methylation status that are linked
in the 3d genome from the same dna
molecules therefore we are able to
calculate the correlation dn methylation
correlation between these two regions
by their 3d genomes better
so if we look at here if we
calculate the correlation if we just
shuffle the rays here
so basically we ignore the length that
is
defined by the the high c steps
that we shot we still use the same
grease in the same region
so they have the same like average
dmsolation level
but then you shuffle the links between
the power reads
and then we calculate the correlations
the correlation
the shutter correlation is much much
lower
than the the imagination that's linked
by this high series so this tells us the
how is the correlation how the
imagination concordance at the same dna
molecular comparing that average
correlation
in this genomic region and we also
measure how is that comparing with a
random
genomic region in genome and how that
in the inter-chromosome reef even in the
intest chromosome grid
it also shows much higher in this linked
width comparing to ramen sharpies
so we also check how is the this
concordance of the methylation in
different compartments
in 3d genome like compartment a you
represent the active component and
compartment
b represents like inactive components
for
if we look at only just linked with
without any
information about their how they whether
or not there's a loop
there we see there's no significant
difference between between these two
compartments
but if we look at the uh region that
they are uh
that is called by quantum groups we see
that there's actually significant
differences
like we get much higher correlation in
component a than compound b since
in component a there's more g regulatory
regions
links and in different content states we
also
observe like in these functional regions
they might have a much
higher uh concordance of the imagination
comparing with the remnant shaft of
links in the same regions
so this uh generation concordance is how
we measure
in each even we get the information in
the same game molecules
we further ask the question what now can
measure this conclusion in a single cell
level
which is more uh like uh which is the
more nuanced way to measure this this
observation so the single film
generation profile
uh will actually help us to get the
entire
gear modulation in the same cells and
how is that concording with each other
in the
in the genomic regions and single cell
high
c is recently also provided way you're
able to calculate the
3d genome information changes in each
different single cells so why
so right right now there's a lot of
single cell
monomials technology like single cell
ions is the tons of signature ionic
technology
and in genomic sequence or single cell
taxi for measured accessibility and the
imagination to measure the
uh the general idealization and system
modification
of 3d genomes so why are we studying the
single cell martial artists
the single cell monomix will provide you
separate the cells according to
different
levels of the epigenetic phase or gene
expression states
but biological system is more
complicated
uh sometimes the joint analysis we hope
that joint analysis of multiple
modality will tell you more information
and helps you to get more neurons cell
types and
intermediate cellular space by using
this different
modality information in single cell
mitotics
so currently there's multiple technology
that's able to do that
like single cell gnome see able to
measure the complete accessibility or
the methylation
and transcriptome also the thing with
the uh
triple omics like an mt stick or triple
stick
uh cortex they're able to measure few
different
omics information and there's also
combination of rna and proteomics
or mmt or gnt to get the genome and the
transcription information
so what we do here is extend we extend
our we further extend our mass high c
technology from bug
to single cell lab so we're able to
simultaneously provide this true
modality and sentient molecular in the
same
single cells so what we did is actually
uh after we the incident hyphen is still
in a box steps
after we solve the nuclei in 9612
then we do the bisulfite conversion in
each well and
after we apply the post bisulfa dm
amplification and single strand adapters
with reaction
we use dual index to ligate and do the
sequence so
the first thing we did is actually we
measure after we merge this each of
single cells
we want to check whether or not we can
get a consistent information at box
method high c so
we did that we merged the cells in each
single cell
so left corner is the merged single cell
macro high c and
right up corner is the box method high c
we actually after we merge this about
100 cell
single cells we get a similar
correlation pattern as block mass ic
and after we get the first pc the
eigenvector
we get a compartment information that
shows similar measurement at the block
high c
uh we also measure the uh the quantum
interaction frequency between the box
and
high c uh block mass of ic and merged
single cell
metal high c and we checked log log can
plot
the mass of height in bark they're
similar as
we did in single cell metal high c at
small vs cell line with two different
cultural conditions and in the regional
wide it looks similar
between the mass height the single cell
mass ic and the box
ic so
we further actually comparing with other
with the not only on the box side we
also compound other the others like
single cell level
single cell monomials so we first
checked our consistency between the two
uh biological replicas in single cell
mass high c they are
the stratified correlation coefficient
are very high
the 0.99 with each other comparing with
a single cell height
and which is similar allowed as a single
cell high c we further comparing the
singleton map i see together with the
single cell high c
saying multiestar lines and cultural
conditions
in a more homogeneous like two eye
cultures
mouth esl they look the the concordance
show much higher
after we merge the 50 cells and in serum
in the serum they which is in the more
sterile cultural condition which is a
more heterogeneity condition
they have less concordance but still
showing high similarity between the
single thermos high c and single cell
high c also we measure the dna
methylation levels
in the serum and 2i people already know
that
the imagination level would be very
different uh
the red dot here represent globe global
dn modulation ladder measured by hogino
by sulphide sequences they showed high
concordance
with their horizon by sulphide
sequencing between our macro hyphen
single cell microhyphae and the single
cell horizon by sulfide sequencing
so
so the next thing is uh
if we get the treatment information can
we use the
uh this imagination information to cross
the cell and get this
the heterogeneity of cells so what we do
here is actually we sequence the mouse
es cell calcium in two different
conditions
the serum m2i and then we cluster
this general migration based on one mac
basis pm methylation density
uh in each cell and then by doing the
disney plot we see that
serum and 2i which mark red and blue
they clearly separate each other
and also their single cell methyl hyphae
can reveal
hydrogenated inside the serum cultured
muscle cells
and after we actually merge this dna
methylation
in each cluster so we get a pseudo-box
methylation level each cluster and then
we cluster these
pseudo-box dna methylation level with
external
dna methylation data from encode
in across different tissues and we see
that cluster 1 is actually expected 2i
are more naive space they are showing
more
out more distinct from the other tissue
types
and class 2 and class 3 they are
clustering
in different groups of the 2 types
and we further did the geo analysis of
this differential methylation region
between the class 2 and class 3
that's a switch in the compartment b to
component a level when we integrate the
3d general information we find that
actually these get
active more activated regions in class
3 they are enriching genesis
and drawing limbogenesis and link
development which is consistent
with the clustering result in panel b
that class
iii are more close with the lymph and
neural facial development
differentiations
and we have the one example plot that's
showing
in class three and class two there's a
switch
at hawks d regions that switch from the
uh from class to the compartment b
which is a repressed space compil uh
switch to accuracy in class three
component a and this is interesting
there's also the
differential magnification region here
at located at ctcf the insulators
which indicates this dmax concordance
imagination changes
together with the uh insulator changes
as well as the 3d genome changes
so since we're able to get this
clustered by the imagination we further
to check whether or not there's
concordant changes of 3d genome there
and genome-wide rather than a single
loci
so we find out like process even with
only sequence
like few very few cells we uh
we merge these cells uh with equals
similar
random number of cells in class one two
and three
we we can see that in class two they're
class three they're very different from
class one
so since we only sequenced a very few
number of cells
at the same at almost the same time just
like one month
after our publications uh doctor echo's
group
um they published the paper they used a
similar technology as we did
and they did in more cells so you can
clearly see here i mean do the keys name
of the two different cell types in mice
and you'll see that
there i've immersed them you'll see that
uh clearly see
there's a distinct dna the 3d genomes
from these two clusters if you classify
uh maximization in methylation
and further they apply this to the
reveal of ketogenic or dementia and 3d
genome human brain
and you can clearly see here by using
non-signature methylation of cpg
methylation
uh in the neural cells uh
in the brain cells in a human brain
cells you're able to distinct
different type of neurons and different
non-neuron cells
and even by using chromatin actions
you'll clearly see some of the
separation
at different cell types
and this is one some of the examples of
some
specific marker genes so definitely this
uh in the future joint classroom of this
martial artist with their spatial
information is needed so we're able to
reveal more nuanced information
here so in summary we developed the
asset called method high c which can
combine things
to high c with bisulfite sequencing to
simultaneously capture the connecting
chromosome conformation changes and dna
methylation on the same dna molecules
and we are able to generate consistent
information to both encl and horizontal
bison by sequencing data from the same
cell line and the methylation is
generally concordant between two dna
fragments
that are spatially closed and methyl
high c can capture dna methylation and
chromatin architecture
that simultaneously in a single cell
and we are able to use mass height
single summation ic to discover
differential quantum coordination and
the methylation into the small
ketogenic cells so this project starts
when i was a post-doc in dr minole's
calyx lab i then finished when i was a
pi in
cincinnati children's hospital medical
center uh thanks for the support from
my postdoc pi postal mentor my noise
kelly
and our collaborator dr binyan and
gordhan
who finished the experiment and thanks
for the founding support for my salary
and the project from
ash growth and foreign nuclear
as well as my startup in cincinnati
children's hospital medical center
thank you if you have any questions
please feel free to ask me
thank you dr liu for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started our first question
is uh it looks like the nuclear capture
rate
is around 40 percent after proximity
ligation
and nuclear sorting so when you were to
look across
samples already what is the rate of
nuclei
that meet your thresholds across
samples so for instance uh if you had
uh you know 20 20 250 000 reads
and 10 000 contacts as your threshold
how many samples can meet that threshold
yeah this is a this very good question
actually we did
one of the reviewer of this paper also
asked the similar questions
and remember we also i can't remember
clearly now but we show this statistic
in the supplement
tables like what is their uh the overall
context in each cell so
generally we get a very high quality of
the library
but indeed we filter out some of the
cells
we did like 2 96 wells
and then and we have about 150 cells
in total for the past hour qc
so i would say yeah a lot of
i mean 150 divided by like 160 96
so there's a large fraction of cells we
still keep in our analysis
i see thank you for your answer
so let's go to our next question
is it possible to predict loop anchors
from concordant methylation profiles
alone
yeah this is a very good question uh
actually we
uh this is actually the
stuff we did when we do the uh when we
do the bark
uh part analysis uh and we try to see
whether or not we can get
uh increase the resolution and just call
the loops based on this like
the method so we not only just called
loose by these theorization concordance
we actually also use the uh we use the
dimension concordance information to
increase the resolution of loops
calling so to define whether or not
there's a functional
concordant region in this local anchor
regions so
actually we get a sequence deep enough
this is a power issue
if we are able to sequence higher and
deeper enough we'll get
even we'll get very good results
but right now since when we do the uh
preliminary analysis
it doesn't show it shows in some regions
we improve the
uh the accuracy but then later we
since we further extended to single cell
level we decided just not incorporate
that part into the final publications
yeah great thank you
so um on to our next question um are the
concordant methylation values within
tads are these regions typically
hypomethylated
in other words what percent of the
contact sites are actually
hypomethylated
so you mean like the uh the loop anchor
region
how many percent of this group of angle
region are hypomethylated
yeah are they are they always typically
hypomethylated or do you ever see
instances where they are not
uh usually they are hypo methylated this
loop because we use a very stringent
calling
by jewish or pipeline to call these
keycaps loops
uh you only get like thousands of these
loops in general y
few few thousand of these loops in
general wide they are very conservative
and high
in which there's this cdcf uh contain
loops and non-cd cell contain
motif contain those uh they both show
somehow their
hypomethylation so next question um
this actually kind of leads from the
last uh
the last question so have you looked at
transcription factor
binding motifs or anything beyond just
ctcf
to see if there's any like say cell type
specific transcription factors that may
help help organize these loops
or is the resolution maybe uh not quite
good enough to see those types of things
yet
uh yeah that's a very good question so
that's also the reason we try to narrow
down and increase the resolution of type
e
using the dms and concordance narrow
down further narrow down
and increase the revolution and then to
check whether or not there's such a
transcription factor binding site
it's definitely a very good direction to
go but
at this paper we didn't mention that
great thank you for your answer um one
more question um
so when you use the single cell
methyl hi-c method particularly in your
presentation
you've shown that it looks at you know
you can look at
cellular differentiation effects like
during embryogenesis
or looking at differentiation of
embryonic stem cells
have you tried to look at say somatic
cells from adult tissues to see
if this could be used for looking at say
disease states in adult tissue
yeah definitely that's that's the uh i
believe the next step
both of beans lab and my lab we're doing
so
when you look at the cpgs in your single
cell
uh methyl high c uh what percent
um of are those cpgs uh in common across
the
captured nuclei yeah it's
it's very sparse i have to admit it
this is the the the problem in like
single cell
dna methylation it's similar as the
single cell horizontal by sequencing
yeah
the data is sparse so if you're doing
like
like single cbd size comparison
across the cells is it's really
challenging
so without imputation it's really
challenging that's why the main purpose
yeah
any analysis we show here is actually
use the one mac basis
uh not overlap window and then do the to
the classroom
and some groups like direct group they
use the 100kb
in overlap window to do that so that one
might get these problems
but indeed that's yeah that's a
challenging
part that's a challenge yeah so this is
more of a technical question
um we noticed in one of your in your
recent publication that you use two
different bisulfite kits
from zymo research and we're kind of
curious uh
is there what was your purpose in using
two different kits
oh you mean like they're in our
publication they're
the box we the park title is gold and in
their
single cell part is lightning right
yeah you think you use gold ender and
direct
and direct sorry yes correct yeah this
is just
okay yeah it's just at the time
uh this is uh actually also i asked for
actually he would be a better person to
answer this question
he told me like at that time they just
happened to have a gold kick there so he
tried that
but then later in the go builds the goal
kit is uh it's good
it's okay for box level but for single
cell lava their input is even lower
uh and we want to like we actually
didn't
so so later he he switched to the dirac
uh example excitement yeah
i see i see yeah thank you for your
answer
so i think we may have time for one more
question um
this is more of a kind of a global
question
what is the future you believe for
single cell methyl high c we've touched
on it a little bit
and what are some of the research
questions or projects
that you believe this method will make
an impact
yeah so this is a very general question
it's also one of the direction we are
going to do
is uh so definitely there's few
direction to go
like one is you can increase the
modality get the
other additional modalities involved in
experiments
and in terms of experiment side or in
terms of their
analysis side as i mentioned in the
presentation like
joint clustering of cells including
including their special information is
challenging
so definitely it's worth to go uh and
in terms of their applications so i
think dragon's group and dr binders
group are doing that right now is extend
this application to different tissue
cell types
there's a lot of ketogenic tissue such
as cancers or
brains which struggle like this in
preformed
cortex and there's also many other
tissue types
uh there's a lot of applications and the
the problem is right now our
understanding about the 3d genome
heterogeneity
in different cells is limited so
for the ketogenic indian methylation
people already
noticed that in the last few years like
since 2014
in a single cell uh gene methylation
sigma cell cholesterol by solar
sequencing or they invented
people look at different cell types and
find out
uh this hydrogenated in different like
dragon's group
the pioneer work find out in different
layers of the neuron they show in
different
gene methylation so maybe in future when
we note
more information more functional about
three digital changes
we'll get more advanced application for
that
that we are able to summatively capture
this
interaction between the two layers
and of course many other layouts
ray thank you so much for your answer um
thank you again
dr yoping lu for your time today and for
presenting your very important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor zymo research
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of your registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you by email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time thanks for attending and
goodbye